this is very left off in the previous
video we saw that plus and minus
separated the terms and multiplication
and division do not separate the terms
of an expression let's look at a few
expressions and find out how many terms
they have here's the first expression 4
plus X we can see a plus sign here it
means that this expression has two terms
4 and X here's the second expression 7
minus X minus y we have two minus signs
here it means that this expression has
three terms seven x and y remember plus
and minus separated the terms
what about seven x / y this expression
involves multiplication and division and
as we know that do not separate the
terms this is just one term what is
seven in this case it's called the
coefficient of x by Y the coefficient of
this how many terms do you think are
present in for X minus y plus seven
this is interesting for X is just one
term since it involves multiplication Y
and seven are the other terms which are
separated by a minus and a plus sign so
this expression has three terms in all
four X Y and seven what about seven XY
plus 20y minus 3z plus eight one term
two three and four four terms in all
each of these is one term here's the
last expression eight X Y Z since it
involves only multiplication this is
just one single term even though there
are three variables and a constant this
is a single term
you